however healthy it often is to try to
fit in and assume we must just be like
everyone else there are also benefits in
sometimes accepting that we might in the
end be simply rather odd
though this needn't be a cause of
particularly concern or shame perhaps we
simply do belong to the peculiar tribe
of those who love above pretty much
anything else to introspect that is to
try to make sense of themselves
to process their emotions
to analyze their immaturities and to
understand the psychological mechanisms
they inhabit
we the happy odd few belong to that
minor clan of avid self-knowers who take
entirely to heart the ancient greek
command to know yourself
to be so intensely concerned with
self-knowledge has probably equipped us
with a number of strange traits
we are likely to very much enjoy our own
company we might not mind spending a
whole day alone marinating in ourselves
it's never a problem if someone cancels
dinner on us
we might keep a diary or a file on our
computer where we spend hours taking
matters apart
we might like hot baths or solitary
walks often in the evening
we might read a lot but in a distinctive
way
always looking out for the ways in which
the words of others shed light on and
more clearly define bits of ourselves
we're likely to be impatient with people
who seek relentlessly to stay on the
surface of things
probably someone once asked us over
dinner slightly defensively why we were
interviewing them and we weren't at all
we were just directing to them some of
the manic curiosity we normally devote
to ourselves
in love
half the fun won't be about sex or
cuddles
it will be that there is someone there
to discuss one of the world's most
interesting phenomena
relationships in real time with us
we might try therapy and even though we
have had our share of disappointing
shrinks it will continue to be an area
of intrinsic fascination
many of our favorite books will be
psychological ones as therapy inspires
us to do so
even though it might have been long
since we lived with our family of birth
we will continue to explore how the past
informs our present
we're never quite done with reflecting
on mum and dad we're no longer angry
with them as we once were we're just
very interested
people may often try to persuade us to
do other things they call fun
go to the beach
come to a party go shopping
and even though we'll agree and they'll
be pleasant moments
the truth is that our favorite pastime
remains sitting at home probably in bed
with a notebook trying to work out what
it means to be alive
that's ideally how after many years we'd
like death to find us
not scared or oblivious but curious and
attentive
wondering what we're about to undergo
and still speculating on what the brief
passage through existence was really all
about
we won't have finished knowing ourselves
but we'll have been most alive whenever
we tried to do so
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face is that of working out who we
really are this book is designed to help
us create a psychological portrait of
ourselves with the use of some unusual
oblique entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more